ses coups de reins étaient à la hauteur
de ses coups de gueule il serait déjà
marié ça va toi
très bien merci merci mon lolo l'équipe
est là oui c'est parti tu peux nous les
présenter à qui ce soit autour de la
table motion j'ai fait un truc façon
grosse tête en vitesse en embrassant à
la naissance une fée lui a proposé
l'intelligence de sa grand mère ou la
tronche de son père je crois qu'il a
fait le mauvais choix benjamins 4
[Applaudissements]
j'aime en allemand depuis que son pote
eux je suis à bloquer tout le train
arrière on l'appelle le labrador et
ribéry
[Applaudissements]
il a plus souvent grand-père la dune du
pilat que le col de l'utérus
si tu dises des afo dans ta présentation
non même quand il fait une fellation
matthieu delormeau articule plus que lui
maxime gagné
[Applaudissements]
je me désolidarise était pas là je te
plait pas je t'ai pas le toit à chaque
intervention elle relance le débat sur
l'euthanasie isabelle moret
je veux dit sur les nerfs ça aussi c'est
pas fini si elles ouvraient une banque
de sperme les donneurs ferait là que
haga topo chico alors je suis pas là
[Applaudissements]
cette affiche s'annonce à ça ça veut
dire alerte c'est ça
ah ah
jackson du malaise mais ça va danser non
pas traduire tout ce qu'il a dit en
anglais connaît pour elle sa rente à
nelson mon bébé à chaque fois qu'ils me
fait greffer un cheveu jean-michel si
ses coups de reins étaient à la hauteur
de ses coups de gueule il serait déjà
mariée elle est toujours derrière elle
est toujours derrière c'est dur à dire
elle est toujours derrière cyril mais un
jour ce sera l'un vers ce qu'elle est et
profite des confrères sans déconner il
croit que c est ça signifie cheikh
sommes astronomiques cyril hanouna
[Applaudissements]